is there something general to say about
what the psychedelics do to the human
mind
you mentioned kind of an ego loss
experience in the space of van diagrams
if we're to like draw a big circle
what can we say about that big circle
in terms of people's report of
subjective
experience probably one of the
most general things we can say is that
it it expands
that range so many people come out of
these sessions
saying that they didn't know it was
possible to have an experience like that
so there's an emphasis on the subjective
experience that
um is is there words that people put it
put to it that capture that experience
or is it something that just has to be
experienced
yeah people what as a researcher that's
an interesting question because you have
to kind of
measure the effects
of this and uh how do you convert that
into numbers
right that that's that's the ultimate
child so how is that even
is that possible to one convert it into
words
and the second convert the words into
numbers somehow so we do a lot of that
with questionnaires you know some of
which are very psychometrically
validated
so they've lots of numbers have been
crunched on them and there's always a
limitation with
with questionnaires i mean subjective
effects are subjective effects
ultimately it's what the person is
reporting and and that doesn't
necessarily point towards
a ground truth um what what they're
so for example if someone says that it
they felt like they touched another
dimension or they felt like they
they sensed the reality of god or if
they
um you know um i mean just you name it
people's ontological
views can sometimes shift i think that's
more about where they're coming from and
i don't think it's the
the quintessential way in which they
work there's plenty of people that hold
on to a completely naturalistic
viewpoint and come and have profound and
and and helpful experiences
with these compounds but the subjective
effects can be so
broad that for some people it shifts
their
their philosophical viewpoint more
towards
idealism more towards you know thinking
of
let that the nature of reality might be
more about
consciousness than about material
that's a domain i'm very interested in
right now we have essentially zero
to say about that in terms of validating
those types of claims but it's even
interesting just to see what people say
along those lines so
you're interested in saying like can we
more rigorously study this
process of expansion like what do we
mean by this expansion of
your sense of what is possible in the
experiences in this world
right as much as what we can say about
that through naturalistic psychology
right especially as much as we can root
it to
um solid psychological constructs and
solid
neuroscientific constructs
you